my news and congratulations on your
BAFTA special I know and now you were
diagnosed when you were very young was
it six rich with a MV now tell us about
that condition yeah so I have an AVM
which stands for arterial venous
malformation so basically you have
arteries capillaries and veins all over
your body and and in the right side of
my face I don't have the capillaries
between the arteries and veins which
causes the veins and computers to the
veins and arteries to collide and this
causes me to have life-threatening
nosebleeds pain swelling and veins to
appear on the right side of my face yeah
this is ongoing and you've had over 40
operations yeah and you're only 15 and I
it's been it's been hard and when I I
was born with the condition but when I
was diagnosed with it my life totally
changed and it was such hard thing to
get to get to grips with really I don't
really understand at such young age what
I had and my my way of life really just
changed and I still touch with the
outside world and or touch with people
my own age and at the age of 8 you
decided that a way for you to help cope
with your condition and to open it up to
people to make people understand was to
start your own YouTube channel yes I I
had always been a childhood that loved
role play and things like that and I
Joy's film little videos on my iPad just
as a way to occupy myself because I
became quite sick quite quickly and
spent so much time at hurt him and one
day I decided to film another one of my
videos on a family iPad and I asked my
mom and dad if I'd be able to put on
YouTube more kind of as my own project
as a way to occupy myself and a way to
put my energy into something because I
had to give up one of my hobbies and I
was left feeling really lonely and
isolated and I my mom and dad were
worried at first because they realized
he knows eight years old I was someone
that looked different and they were
worried how people would react but they
decided that if they died so would the
comments at first it could be a really
great thing for me and a really great
thing to build back up my confidence
that I had before I was diagnosed and
say I posted my first video and have
never looked back it's interesting isn't
it because we talk about social media
now for young people and
you know they spend so much of their
time there yeah it's you know an online
life as it became for you and but it can
be a hostile environment so what was the
reception like online for you when you
arrived looking different talking about
what you were going through when my
comments were off obviously I wasn't
really sure how people were reacting
because all I saw was likes and I didn't
at the time actually know you can even
get subscribers and but when we enabled
the comments I was a bit worried because
I'd grown up and I realized actually not
everyone's very nice online and
obviously you know you're going to get
the negative with the positive that's
just how it works when you expose
yourself to the world but there was so
many positive comments that although I
did get you know you're ugly and why do
you look like that and things like that
it really did outweigh the negative and
I felt so grateful that I'd started it
and the support was just astounding I
felt very grateful it really did spur me
on were you being rewarded because not
only are you educating young people your
condition and just being different in
general and celebrating that but also
educating adults as well and you're
having a lot of fun along the way
because when your big passions is baking
yeah love and bake up I'm loving your
eyeshadows okay getting my own tips off
camera for that and but talk to us about
you know how that is inspiring other
people well I think there have been a
lot of hobbies that I found since being
diagnosed you know like you've mentioned
baking and makeup and I think what I
want to show people is that you know I'm
an average teenager but I'm not I've
been through quite a few hardships in my
life but I want to show people that you
know no matter what you can achieve your
dreams you've just got to be determined
and persevere and you know you are
enough and it's okay not to be okay
everyone has bad days and you know on my
bad days obey can I do my makeup and
those have been really great ways to
distract myself via normal teen exactly
yeah just doing what everybody likes
saying I think not letting my condition
stop me from doing what an average teen
would do
and normally you sit in the chair I'm
sitting cuz you're so did you do
celebrity I think I've seen Andy Murray
on your YouTube channel Jamie Oliver
yeah it's quite crazy actually because I
mean I've been able to do anything
nearly meets three you know it started
through YouTube really and it's it's
quite crazy because I mean I must say I
do prefer being
interviews it's a lot less daunting but
it's I feel so lucky that I've been able
to meet so many of my heroes and people
that I look up to you and I've made
friends for life and it's just they've
all taught me something and I've been
learnt so much and it's been amazing